في بريطانيا ولليوم الثالث على التوالي
يضرب نحو 1400 موظف في الحراسه الامنيه عن
العمل في المحطه الخامسه في مطار هترو
لندن لمطالبه بزياره الاجور واعادت اداره
المطار انها استدقت الاضراب بخطه الطوارئ
تشمل توظيف الف موظف اضافي واستعانه
بالعاملين لديها لتخفيف من تداعياته وقال
المدير التنفيذي لمطار هيثرو ان العمل في
المطار يسير كالمعتاد
تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره من حرب اذا حسب
مدير المطار الحركه
كالمعتاد رغم الاضراب
اهلا عبد الصمد هو كذلك فعلا لان المطار
اداره المطار استفقت هذا الاضراب الذي
يستمر عشره ايام ويتزامن مع عطله الاسفار
التي تتزامن مع عيد الفصح وهي عطله دراسيه
هنا في بريطانيا بحيث يسافر عدد من
البريطانيين خارج البلاد لكنها سبقت بخطه
الطوارئ التي شملت كما ذكرتم اضافه موظفي
الاستعانه بوكالات التوظيف الخارجيه
لاضافه موظفين للقيام بالعمل الذي تركه
هؤلاء المضربون عن العمل اضافه الى
الاستعانه بالعمال من محطات المطار الاخرى
نذكر بان الاضراب يطال فقط المحطه الخامسه
وهي المحطه التي تستخدمها حصريا الخطوط
الجويه البريطانيه الخطوط الجويه
البريطانيه نفسها كانت قد سبقت هذا
الاضراب بحيث الزمت على الغاء 5% من
رحلاتها من والى المطار وذلك بما يعادل
حوالي 30 رحله يوميا اي 300 رحله
ايام هذا الاضراب بالنسبه لاداره المطار
تقول بانها لن تسمح للمضربين بان يضعوا
المسافرين رهينه لمطالبهم التي قالت بانها
قد قامت بما يلزم من اجل تسويه الوضع او
هذا النزاع مع النقابه بحيث ان عرض زياده
بعشره في المئه في اجور هؤلاء الموظفين
الا ان النقابه تقول بان هذا غير كافي في
ظل الازمه ازمه المعيشه التي تعيشها
البلاد ذلك بان الموظفين معظم هؤلاء
يتقاضون رواتب اجورا لمقابل اثني عشر
جنيها استرليني لكل ساعه وهو حقيقه ناصر
عبد الصمد غير كافي في ظل ازمه المعيشه
والتكاليف الغاديه المرتفعه والفواتير
المرتفعه ايضا فواتير الكهرباء والماء
والايجار كل هذه يعني ازمه التضخم القياسي
التي تعيشها البلاد دفع تعديد من القطاعات
ونقبات عماليه اخرى الى الخروج في سلسله
من الاضرابات التي
بريطانيا منذ الاشهر الماضيه من التعليم
والصحه وايضا نتوقع اضرابات يعني قادمه ان
في قطاع الصحه اذا صوت في الحادي عشر من
ابريل الجاري التي يقوم بها وينظمها
الاطباء المتدربون نتوقع ان يعني ان تبدا
المستشفيات في انجلترا بتحذير المرضى بعدم
القدوم الى المستشفيات والغاء عدد من
المواعيد مع طول قائمه الانتظار في هذه
المستشفيات تمتد الى اكثر من مليون شخص
ينتظرون رؤيه الطبيب او العلاج في هذه
المستشفيات لكن كما ذكرت الحكومه تصارع
الزمن من اجل يعني تسويه تسويه هذه
النزاعات مع النقابات المعنيه بالعمال
وهناك يعني محاولات من قبل الحكومه
لزياده هذه الرواتب بشكل يتماشى مع نسبه
التضخم اشكرك من حرب مراسله الجزيره من
مطار هيترو لندن شكرا لك